bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors c'est une décision
importante
une bonne nouvelle même pour les
éditeurs de presse oui alors ils peuvent
alors comme on voit ce qui a été négocié
avec qui mais pour le moment ça va dans
un bon sens c'est certain alors le point
central dans cette affaire c'est bien
évidemment le droit voisin qu'est ce que
c'est concrètement et quelles sont ses
limites
pourquoi parler de droits voisins sans
parler de droits d'auteur parce que
c'est un droit qui ça colle au droit
d'auteur le droit d'auteur c'est un
droit qui permet à l'auteur ce sont des
faits sur sa création une exclusivité et
ça lui permet de donner une autorisation
ou un refus sur son exploitation
c'est cette autorisation générale qui
est accompagné d'une rémunération le
droit voisin lui qui s'affolent en fait
aux droits d'auteur est exercée par une
personne qui va donner vie à leurs veaux
première c'est à dire qu'il va
l'interpréter qui va la diffuse
équivalent à produire et c'est sur cette
interprétation sur cette continuité qui
le donne à l'oeuvre qu'on va donner un
droit un droit qui est similaire aux
droits d'auteur puisqu'il va permettre
d'autoriser ou de refuser son
exploitation et cette autorisation va de
pair effectivement en général avec une
rémunération pour ce qui est de ce droit
voisin il est très proche du droit
d'auteur on a un droit moral est un
droit patrimonial et il ya des
exceptions comme la représentation
privée la copie privée est la parodie la
caricature le court extrait et ce droit
voisin il est très spécifiques
concernant en fait la typologie de
personnes qui l'exercent que ce soit un
artiste interprète un producteur une
entreprise de communication est donc
maintenant est ce qu a instauré la
directive et la nouvelle
loi de 2019 c'est que maintenant on a un
droit voisin pour les éditeurs de presse
et c'est tout le sujet de ce conflit
entre google et les éditeurs de presse
alors via google donc tu va accepter
manifestement de rénumérés les éditeurs
de presse jusque là il refusait de le
faire est ce que google en saas mettez
au dessus de la langue française
c'est vrai que l'attitude de google
était très particulière parce que ils
s'affranchissent est complètement de ce
texte
alors il n'était pas en infraction avec
la loi
parce que la loi permet d exception
c'est à dire que il faut demander
l'autorisation et une rémunération aux
éditeurs de presse
sauf si on utilise un lien hypertexte
qui renvoie au contenu à l'article à la
publication et sauf en cas de ces
exceptions je citais tout à l'heure de
courte citation et donc google a dit moi
je vais je garde les slips ex pour vous
donc je vous laisse une diffusion tout
en haut du moteur de recherche vous
mettant bien en valeur et en échange
vous les éditeurs de presse d'une fête
et l'essence gratuite ce qui était
permis par la loi donc ce chantage en
fait à créer une des conflits entre les
histoires de presse et 90% d'entre eux
ont été obligés de dire bon d'accord on
cède on donne des licences gratuites
parce qu'on a besoin de visibilité et
google avait dit sinon si vous
n'acceptez pas moi je mettrais que des
liens hypertextes et du coup vous
n'aurez qu'une visibilité et
l'internaute pourra via le lien
retrouver votre article et votre contenu
sur votre site
donc non c'était pas une infraction à la
loi
mais c'était clairement un contournement
un affranchissement de
à part de google qui qui qui a
instrumentalisé la loi et les exceptions
qu'elle composait margot un
carillon vous êtes avocat de valmy
spécialisé en droit de la propriété
intellectuelle
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt france